hi my name is Ryan Johnson and I'm a Data Science
Advisor here at Posit and I'm excited to host
our first ever Posit team Community demo on
April 26th and we'll continue this series of
demos on the last Wednesday of every month going
forward now during these demos we'll walk through
an end-to-end data science workflow using our
three professional data science tools that make
up Posit team. Posit workbench, Posit connect
and Posit Package Manager. Now most importantly
these events are open to the entire data science
Community now you may ask yourself like why would
I want to attend these posit team demos so here
are a few reasons why I believe these sessions
will be valuable not just to Posit customers
but also the greater data science community
so first off maybe you've never heard of Posit
before either you're new to a company that uses
Posit Team or you're just exploring options
for your team's analytics platforms so during
these demos we'll make sure to provide a high
level overview of Posit Team and also highlight
some of the newest features we've added to
our toolchain now secondly maybe you do use
Posit Team today and you're looking to expand
your data science capabilities for example is
your team thinking about using python more maybe
creating some Dash applications or hosting your
first API every month we'll keep things fresh and
discuss a new topic and touch upon the various
capabilities within Posit Team and finally this is
a great time to ask us at Posit any questions
you have about Posit Team. During this demo we'll behanging out in the chat to answer any and all
of your questions you have about Posit workflows
capabilities licensing and more. we hope these
demos are valuable to you and your data science
team and we look forward to seeing you there